[ Up-tempo theme music plays ]
-"Circuit breakers don't flip,
they trip."
I got them confused
with break-dancers.
[ Laughter ]
"A Toshiba T1100 wouldn't have
the processing power
to burn your thighs."
[ Laughter ]
Computers used to be slow,
but they weren't hot as [Bleep].
[ Laughter ]
You could play Prince of Persia
for 12 hours,
and we did.
Your thighs would be
cool as ice.
[ Laughter ]
You could store meat on them.
I said Whiskers wasn't
a person's last name.
But some of you did
a little research check,
checked places
like ancestry.com,
and figured out somewhere
between 700 to 850 people
currently have that last name.
I guess it was a common surname
for cake makers.
I don't have a lot of confidence
about tonight's "Corrections."
[ Laughter ]
Joyce did a lot.
Joyce sent in a lot.
And so sometimes I feel like
it's gonna be red-hot,
and -- Yeah.
Like, if you got a ton
going on today or tonight
or whenever you're watching it,
you can skip it.
[ Laughter ]
A lot of people came out
in defense of the Compass app
on the iPhone.
Some ecologists said it
comes in very handy for them.
And a few people said,
"You should be careful
what you say.
If you're lost
in the wilderness,
it's incredibly helpful."
Just make sure it's a wilderness
where all the trees
have outlets.
[ Laughter ]
Just look,
if you need a compass,
get a compass.
Get a practical --
Don't count on
your phone's compass.
You can't over-rely
on technology.
I could get a teleprompter,
but I use Wally,
because, for his faults,
never --
Battery has never gone dead.
[ Laughter ]
During H.R. meetings,
goes low -- gets low.
[ Laughter ]
Definitely been like
somewhere between 3% and 5%
at a couple of
those H.R. meetings.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Wally,
I often tell him --
not in the body of the show --
I say, "Stop interrupting
my monologue,"
because he'll -- he'll talk.
And one of you wrote,
"It's impossible for him
to interrupt a monologue,
because as soon as he talks,
it's a dialog."
This is the [Bleep]...
[ Laughter ]
...I got to put up with.
[ Sighs ]
Did a "Jokes Seth Can't Tell"
this week.
A banger, by the way,
worth watching.
A really good one.
Jackal wrote,
"You need to change
the graphic of Seth
in the opening package."
And I immediately thought,
"That's a great point,
because I'm wearing a suit,
old haircut."
You know what?
Good work, Jackal.
Actually thought, "Look at that.
A helpful note from a Jackal,"
then kept reading.
"You need to change the graphic
of Seth in the opening package.
He looks so much older now."
[ Laughter ]
Di-- Distinguished.
Also in that segment, I joked
that when I blow out
my birthday candles,
I wish for lesbian twins.
Jenny took offense,
as per uzhe.
[ Laughter ]
But one of you ran to my defense
and said, "Shame on Jenny."
I didn't say I wish for lesbian
twins for sexual reasons.
She just jumped
to that conclusion.
Maybe I wish for them
because I needed
some woodworking done
and wanted to support
a family business.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe a correction
Seth can't tell?
[ Laughter ]
We said -- We showed a picture
of Bernie Sanders,
um, in "Star Wars."
And we --
we called it a cruiser.
We should have said --
uh, "Star Wars" --
We should have said
an X4 Landspeeder.
It's alright, nerds. Um...
[ Laughter ]
Talked about
President Biden's train trip.
Secret train trip
to Ukraine from Poland.
Showed a stock photo of a train.
Many said it was a German train.
I want to clear that up
right away,
because when it comes
to attention to detail,
I consider train enthusiasts
the knitting community on rails.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, speaking of
the knitting community,
you guys remember
my famous sweater vest,
knitted by
the great Patty Lyons?
Well, you might also remember
this whole thing --
whole "Corrections" universe
started with a Lego error,
and somebody made this
to commemorate
what we're doing.
Look at this. It is a --
It is a version of me
in my sweater vest,
made made of Lego.
Pretty impressive.
And then they go --
and this goes with it.
And you guys will probably
figure this out faster,
because I -- I was like,
"Is this like a Landspeeder X4?"
And then I realized...
[ Laughter ]
I think this is...
Really...
[ Laughter ]
So, that's nice.
I'm going to put that
over here for now.
We are gonna have to
clean this up.
We're gonna do, like, a --
Yeah, we'll do, like, a, um --
a March Madness thing --
you know, like
Tournament of Things we did,
first year.
Very popular.
[ Laughter ]
We'll do, like, a --
You'll have to vote.
If something stays,
something goes.
And this is a mess right now.
So you go over
to seacaptainpolls.com,
blow the dust off it, and, uh...
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, hey, guys,
is this a nice --
is this a nice gift?
Is this something
that you would send --
you would go out of your way
to send in the mail
to a person who's made it clear,
a certain phobia he has
about a former fast-food mascot?
Here, can you give me
a little --
Can we give me a candle here --
camera here?
Excuse me. Just heads?
[ Laughter ]
Just to see -- Just...
a hundred heads of this...
If you want to buy these
for a friend,
just go on Amazon and
search for the devil's teeth.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, last week,
while just discussing
Bruce Springsteen's
album "Nebraska,"
I suggested Springsteen
would never sing the song
"Mansion on the Hill"
in concert.
He has played that song
138 times in concert...
[ Laughter ]
...including just
last month in Florida.
A Springsteen fanatic said
I should have said
"State Trooper" or "Used Cars,"
which are the least played
Springsteen songs in concert --
38 times each.
"Used Cars," of course.
Do you remember that song?
It's where he tries
to sell all the cars
he's mentioned in other songs.
[ Laughter ]
Pink Cadillacs, '69 Chevy.
[ Snickers ]
[ Laughter ]
If you're on a budget,
we got some skeleton frames
of burned-out Chevrolets.
[ Laughter ]
Someone asked,
what is my favorite
Springsteen album
if it's not "Nebraska"?
I don't know.
It's either "Wild --"
"The Wild and the Innocent,"
or "Born to Run."
Gun to my head, desert island,
I can only bring one,
I don't know.
I think I might have to bring
"Born to Run"
because "Thunder Road" is
my favorite Springsteen song.
So I don't know.
It's certainly not "Nebraska."
However, if I could only bring
one movie to a desert island,
it would be "Nebraska"
starring Will Forte.
[ Laughter ]
Which you haven't seen --
if you haven't seen,
is like a less-funny
"MacGruber."
[ Laughter ]
Or a more funny "MacGruber,"
depending on where you fall
on "MacGruber."
Very polarizing film.
[ Laughter ]
People have been saying
recently --
and I think it's true,
and I think it's a credit
to people
who come every week --
that this would be impossible
to follow
if you didn't start
from the beginning.
And you know,
I do encourage everybody
who's watching this
for the first time
and, you know,
frustrated by the fact
that they don't have a pause
or stop on their laptop...
[ Laughter ]
...on the phone with
their IT guy right now,
and be like, "Won't [Bleep]
stop playing!"
[ Laughter ]
So I was thinking, like,
"Should we do it?
Because we're coming up on 75.
We're not gonna do
a big spectacular.
But should we start
releasing them
from the beginning,
as a podcast?"
You know, would that be
a helpful way
for people to catch up?
So I guess my question
for Leiderman would be,
if you go connect
with the NBC podcast people
and then get back to me,
do you think
we could get an answer
in like 10 months?
[ Laughter ]
Also, should we start --
I think, you know,
we've done this
for so many years now,
the dates are less helpful.
Like, maybe we should,
in the YouTube description,
put episode number.
You can still put the date,
but I think maybe
the episode number
would be helpful.
And you might be saying,
"Hey, Seth,
isn't this a conversation
you should be having
with Leiderman
during the workday?
Why are you doing it
in the body of 'Corrections'?"
Well, I want to do it like this.
No follow-ups.
[ Laughter ]
Popes can have kids.
The pope's gonna have kids,
you guys.
Alexander VI had
at least seven.
Popes are allowed to have --
I did not realize --
as many kids as they want
under the ecclesiastical canon.
The specific one
that allows them
to have as many kids
as they want
is the Nick Cannon.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's the sound
of a puzzle piece
fitting perfectly, you know?
Don't go looking for them.
Sometimes they just
come and find me.
[ Laughter ]
And of course, popes can
physically have children.
You know?
unless they have
a medical procedure
known in the Catholic faith
as a Vatican-ectomy.
[ Laughter ]
I told you.
[ Sighs ]
It's just they were, like,
all terrible puns this week.
[ Laughter ]
That's not what I set out to do,
but then....
Well, this one's not.
We said Bernie Sanders' finger
was like a samurai sword.
And then we also said
he kept it in a holster.
"If it was a sword,
it would be kept in a scabbard,
a sheath, or a saya,
which is the Japanese word
for 'sheath.'"
And if you forget it,
it's easy to remember
because if you encounter
a samurai
and they put their sword away,
you breathe a [Inhales deeply]
sigh o' relief.
[ Laughter ]
It cost -- It cost us all
a little bit,
but you won't forget it.
[ Laughter ]
It's time for "Animal Flubs."
Are you guys
not gonna do the song?
-Uh, no.
We're, uh, not gonna
sing the song today,
because I read
the YouTube comments,
and someone wrote, quote,
"I gotta say,
the 'Animal Flub' song
[Bleep] sucks.
It's not funny.
And not in the anti-humor
kind of way.
It's grating and it's boring,"
end quote.
-What a son of a aaah!
Ech.
[ Laughter ]
We joked that someone
drove, uh -- crashed their car
into a drive-through
because they were
out of biscuits.
And that they needed
the biscuits
because it takes the edge
off the meth.
But someone said
that doesn't track,
because meth is
an appetite suppressant.
So you wouldn't take it and
then want biscuits that badly.
And actually meth
is taking advantage of this.
They're rebranding themselves,
Shoemaker.
[ Laughter ]
You've probably seen the ads.
"Meth -- the poor man's
Ozempic."
[ Laughter ]
Alright.
Last thing --
and this is for our friends
over at YouTube,
because we don't do
the closed captioning.
Okay?
So you can criticize
the closed captioning
all you want.
We have nothing to do with it.
I do appreciate
that YouTube does it.
Very happy that people who rely
on closed captioning have it.
But sometimes I need you
to make some editorial decisions
and think before you put it in
how it's going to look
to the viewer.
Now, last week
I'm wearing mosquito headpiece.
I didn't know ahead of time
that the antenna
we're gonna be falling
into my face.
So, out of necessity,
I'm blowing them out of my face.
Like, that's not a thing, right?
Like, even if
you are hearing-impaired,
you can tell that
I'm blowing, right?
There's no reason
to put that in.
Because here's the problem.
It's just a picture of me,
and it says "blows."
[ Laughter ]
Who's that for? You know?
Like, just I think,
in general, like,
let's all just do better.
[ Laughter ]
We've done this --
We've done like 74 of these.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, and some weeks,
I don't have an out.
[ Laughter ]
See me next week.